y la mi su socio preparan los panes que
enviarán en unas pocas horas al frente
de batalla para alimentar a cientos de
hombres que defienden la provincia de
odessa
no tenemos experiencia desde el punto de
vista militar los militares nos dijeron
que teníamos que esperar por la segunda
ola porque por el momento tenemos la
primera y la segunda así que hablamos
entre nosotros y decidimos que podíamos
hornear el pan ayudar a la gente y así
lo hicimos de heres
[Aplausos]
la invasión rusa llegó solo un par de
meses después de haber puesto en marcha
este proyecto soñado en el que buscaban
producir el mejor pan de la ciudad como
la mayoría de negocios en odessa está
cerrado y sin clientes
si no hacemos esto vamos a tener que
irnos muchos de nosotros nos iremos y
los rusos vendrán y desafortunadamente
harán lo que quieran y nosotros no
queremos que ellos estén aquí
este es uno de esos pequeños
restaurantes que hacen parte de esa gran
oferta gastronómica de odessa y esta es
una de las cocinas más importantes de la
ciudad pero ahora en este momento cocina
700 platos no solamente para el ejército
sino para los voluntarios de la defensa
territorial ellos pudieron haber cerrado
como muchísimos otros restaurantes pero
su dueño y los que trabajan aquí
decidieron cooperar y ayudar a estas
personas que están defendiendo el país
le pedimos a la gente que nos ayudara
que trajera ingredientes y que donarán
dinero para comprarlos y poco a poco
este proyecto se hizo más grande
esta cocina se parte hoy de la
iniciativa que apoya la organización
world kitchen night que lidera el chef
español josé andrés y que les ha apoyado
con alimentos nos mandan mensajes saben
que cocinamos para ellos vemos esos
mensajes todos los días tenemos un gran
respeto por esa gente y estamos juntos
con un solo corazón
yo quiero